all right four people joining this
livestream this is kind of the late
stages of version 12 release development
we're doing some what we call knitting
making sure that documentation pages
reference each other correctly and so on
so let's start off with something that
doesn't sound very exciting web window
object represents an window great I
don't think you want to say an window um
okay so was that trying to say an open
window object or does that not true that
it's an open window object it can be a
window or a tab so open right now a
window or tab
an active window or tab or something an
open it has to be an open one right open
window or tab in a web browser correct
okay remember what is the open close
here that there's a bunch of stuff
inside it right great
it's meant to have a dot type thing okay
so what attributes of a web window
object can you look at if I get a web
window object what can I do with it
so it's like if I go here and I say web
execute of um open I wait a minute why
isn't the sort of completing has that
been dealt with the autocomplete um do
you understand the issue we're not Auto
completing the commands correctly here
did you get what I'm saying yes I think
I commented on that before is Ann and
Andrea here yes okay can you go chase
that please okay
okay what did that just do why did it
produce a red thing here
that was really weird what that did did
you see what that did
i I do reproduce the issue in the latest
bills I'll look into it but Garrett this
is your code right so and also more
seriously that red syntax error is
completely incomprehensible to me make
sense look at this okay so it flashed
weird stuff on my screen it failed well
this time I didn't produce the red thing
there but that red thing is really
suspicious make sense Roz you saw that
yes I do reproduce it too I'll chase it
okay but do also reproduce the failure
Garrett can you speak to the failure of
this okay Oh what just happened it
opened the page and then the page
disappeared Garrett hey yeah yeah so you
said it should work like the external
evaluate so it opens runs the command or
commands and then closes so it's opening
the page and then and then what ending
the session what I thought it gave a web
session wait a minute so I see web
execute doesn't do that Web Start web
session gives you this session okay so
then okay so what gives me back a I
would have expected a web execute of
open web page to give me back a web
window object but it doesn't great
that's a start web session then I get
that and then I say web execute is that
right with respect to that web session
great and then I say this open page
thing is that correct to get back though
window objects or just oh no how do I
get back the window object there's
separate commands browser windows
browser windows great why is it that
that one doesn't that ight the thing I
just okay
does it know what what what I mean
that's pretty obscure that window ID
great now does it know what the title of
the tab is title of the pages cuz it
should show me that because otherwise I
don't have a hope in hell of figuring
out what these are so there's a separate
command I think it's page title which
will give the title of the page but
that's for the current browser then
which one's focused well so I say you
know that for the web window object or
not for the individual web window
objects they don't know that because
they'd have to send out and get the
query back and in theory they could but
it might require you know more code
underneath well it's a wait a minute why
don't you make it so that a sub value
here will give me the page title of this
if I say this thing and then I say that
of page title for example that would I
would think be consistent with great
well what are there any things that
aren't that are available from the web
window object right now it doesn't have
you know any good useful things to come
back it shouldn't do this it should give
it it should either remain on evaluated
or give an error in this case right
right well if it has a key what kind of
a key doesn't have any keys it's it's
just what are you talking about so the
browser in window ID should compare it
so that so you're saying it does in fact
have properties great but not very
useful ones well but you should document
the properties it has I mean
okay but maybe we should give it some
useful ones like page title and so on
that make sense I would think sense okay
so once you figure out what those should
be and then um okay so that's not really
relevant here
I mean this is okay this is um okay okay
so first of all web execute of session
comma browser windows that correct yep
gives the current gives list the current
list of web window objects gives um
current list of web window objects for a
session for a web session okay
[Music]
the following web execute commands
operate on Windows specified by
you
make a window active is that I mean okay
okay what does it do
um what does it do when you set the
window position wet work to the XY what
is the XY mean so that's in pixels in
relation to I guess the origin of your
main window so 100 100 will just be
inside if you're the top left corner of
your main wind screen in screen okay is
that the same positioning that we have
for the notebook system I believe so
that's what I say if I say set if I say
web execute and I'm gonna do the same
thing with a set window position here
this is pretty weird frankly the way
this works
okay so then I say
percent 29 comma 100 100 you claim
you
I put a bunch of garbage in
oh wow
you
you
okay that put it there okay so now let's
try moving my current window set options
of evaluation no book I think it's
called window position No
okay see also window margins that's
right
oh yeah this is kind of complicated
right because it because it defects we
know margins
okay
humph so this works differently okay I'm
making sense great so it's not obviously
wrong what you have but but it's
definitely different
um where do we document that
we don't documented is that well what
about him web execute great so the WebEx
cube has the same message
why does set window size not work here
and why does get window position not
work here I think those aren't listed
just because they didn't have directly
work on a window object but though you
can apply the window object right right
so they are related so like get window
position will get the current position I
believe okay so so we're not gonna have
this for twelve but the following
properties
no we basically want to say web web
window object of this with properties by
the way Ethan while livestream comments
that the red cell brackets are being
seen all over the place
presumably in the version 12 beta so
that might be a 64-bit front-end ursu
Raj
yep yeah sorry I was muted okay um
computes can't
properties I suggest that we have some
things like
you know
I'm not completely sure why one of these
is called window size and one is called
get window position why is it called gap
window position sophistical window
position right so so get and set
functions or names like that just
because they're somewhat paired but this
one doesn't called get this one is just
called window size right I see so
there's a mistake here yeah it okay with
that okay so let's get rid of this and
let's call that just window position
here
okay so then okay so then in fact we've
got some other things here that we need
to include the window position
I mean the fact is this is probably what
should work window size
window position
um
why doesn't window full screen work so
window full screen kind of applies to
the whole browser so it changes okay
essentially I don't know my web execute
can't take a web window object instead
of a web session as its first argument
because it should know about the session
from the window yeah yeah but yes that's
what I'm saying right that makes some
sense I think that looks more convenient
in this case but I think it also makes
web execute maybe do more than I think
it should work web execute should um
yeah I don't see any reason that
wouldn't work since the web window
object already knows about the web
session right you think that makes sense
okay so minor things that need to be
added to this okay okay so I assume web
session points to I don't really like
the way that's done why doesn't this
point to web window object web window
object was just recently added so we
wanted to make sure it got reviewed
before we finished kind of knitting the
links to it there's just some kind of
straggling functions that we worried we
didn't think we'd be able to have until
a little bit later okay
all right web window object so then
okay what was the other one that we were
supposed to be knitting dollar ssh
authentication I believe okay so that's
a completely different thing okay so
this needs to go on to a
[Music]
you
you
you
okay so here we just have to say we have
window object symbolic representation of
an open web page or tab right not
correct yep that's correct
you
okay
you
you
you
we might as well put it in there
you
okay all right web window object is
knitted um
actually you know what this should refer
to notebook object and notebook object
should refer to it and can you please
make it so that web execute operates on
web window objects and then we'll have
to fix certain documentation not
necessary for 12-point oh sure okay um
Ali from our livestream says white is
running the same code in the front end
take much less time running in a dot M
file after each evaluation for another M
file gives a different timing is that a
version 12 beta issue I don't know it's
for you Raj I'll take a look says he has
a
our tracking code that runs in 30
seconds in the front and approximately a
minute from dot M script that's really
weird yeah I well without a concrete
example okay I'll try to reproduce it
later okay okay can you appreciate it
ally if you could send your beta test
contact more detailed information so we
can track that down
since Raj doesn't seem to know what that
would be um okay let's go to ssh
authentication my gosh what on earth so
this one this page is still pretty
graphite intended to review look over
this whole bit more throw them in and
bring that up in the meeting with him
but we could go over it now if you would
like to well not particularly where did
this come from so this is this was meant
as a default kind of option so if
someone wants to set authentication
options for connecting to a remote kind
of machine with they could set all of
their defaults using this variable and
then they would be used in those
functions I don't understand this I
don't understand I you know if you've
got seven different machines your
connection to SSH I don't just want one
of these things here right so you could
provide at least with the keys it will
work with a list of keys username and
password I don't think it takes a list
for them so if you're connecting to
several different machines then this
might not be the best variable I don't
think this is right I'm sorry I don't
think it's right you and Roman probably
need to talk to me about it okay okay
have a think about it yourselves but it
to me I don't understand why this isn't
part of the dollar system servers
mechanism where you can say for
different or rather the system
credentials mechanism well I guess those
are two connected things where you can
say for different servers
what authentication information you want
to provide get what I'm saying yeah that
makes sense
and then have a default there I would
think so I don't know what this is and
I'm suspicious about it and I'm not sure
it should be in twelve Oh unless it um I
I really don't get this I'm sorry I I
really don't get it so that needs to be
discussed separately okay test file name
this is a slightly crazy thing in my
opinion but I guess it's harmless enough
um yeah fair enough
does it say here that verification test
wait a minute does it say here that it
uses dollar test file name I don't
believe it has been knitted into any
other page yet okay well who knows about
this particular thing um I mean I would
end to fondled the beach huh no so why
don't you tell me what what it should
say here um I mean it's it's used as a
symbol - I understand but just what
should it say on this page and a
verification test does this say that um
when running a verification test dollar
test file name what should it say just
tell me or is it an test report yeah I
mean it's technically part of test
report okay fine um
okay test report sets dollar test file
name um let's see - the name of the file
from which the current test what should
it say here is that is that correct or
right I mean it gives the name off the
table anything it doesn't give anything
that's not what this is talking about
this is talking about test report what
your test reports say so I'm saying this
is this talks about what does test
report do with dollar test file name I
mean it it's it's a quick handler
function to return if you want a
reference no no no test report when you
run test report right
it runs several files right okay so
right now we only support you know you
can map it or several files but the only
support test report runs on a single
file we don't support directories or you
know list of files yeah
so then so then when it's running test
report set stall a test file name - the
name of the file in from which a test is
being run is that right correct
like currently executing desk file it's
the name of the file but so this should
be within verification test right it
should say - the name of the file from
which a test verification test can be
standalone usually testify I understand
but but when okay how much a test is run
if a test is given explicitly if if what
would a stall a test file name in the
case where you're running us explicit
verification test it would be null null
isin no no it should be none none yeah I
meant none like an empty string
basically no no no no no no no no no no
it should be the symbol none okay we try
to be consistent with dollar input file
name and it returns you know empty
string if it couldn't find any I'm sorry
what are you talking about it shouldn't
return an empty string so if you go to
dollar input file name or just a value
dollar input file name in your front end
you'll see returns you know that this
meeting wasn't supposed to be a design
review of all this stuff this was
supposed to be reviewed separately so
that's probably wrong but I mean that's
so deeply burnt into the system at this
point we probably can't change it
sure I'm just saying that when we
designed all a test file name we we kind
of modeled it after dollar input file in
and I mean if you wanted to return none
we could we could as well no I mean I
don't know I don't know if we wants a
whatever I really don't like this
particular law
this particular thing very much I think
it's kind of hacky hopefully it's useful
to you I mean you put it in because you
need it right um some users of this has
requested for a reference to the test
file name when the test report is being
run because if they want to load any
code in that directory where the test
file is this this is pretty useful I say
well why don't they just say current
directory oh I see where the test file
is correct and it's also useful if you
want to print out any debugging
information especially let's say you're
mapping it over several test file names
and you know um it's a very small
utility ok
you
the name of the file from which a test
is being run
is that right yes
I'm thinking about how to put that on
this page I'm gonna do this okay
it's knitted um I don't think we still
need Garrett write them and we finished
off the operation so perhaps he can drop
off I think so okay thank you thanks Oh
Ali on our live stream sends through an
interesting link to a paper but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna click on this right
now I'd love to click on this but if I
click on this
we're distracting totally but thank you
actually I'm really I'm not going to not
going to I'll follow it up after the
meeting okay I'm just curious to see the
paper but anyway um github link um okay
what's next here um so the device
framework stuff I thought I put I
thought I'd knitted the device framework
stuff so the way that gets knitted is
into these global guide pages for
example in this case it is about there
is a page about devices right um not yet
you had a question yes yes there is this
there is there's a page isn't there
there's a page there's a guide page by
the way I think those arrows are in the
wrong place here those seem like they're
low yeah I I see it okay
well there it is except that that's
wrong those dot dots are the wrong
format but otherwise this is knitted
it's fine okay
right I mean simulated cart bull it's
not knitted because we don't want to
knit it okay and eventually we're going
to have a page with all the vise types
but for right now that will be simply
something which appears in the machine
learning you know example pages ok ok
I'll get these get this fixed I'll take
care of it the um okay um just just to
double-check which page should go to or
should that be removed completely I said
just fix the format it shouldn't go
anywhere oh yeah okay just fix the
format so that it is corrected fine fine
okay
I don't even know I let me let me check
something here um so I think this is an
issue yeah you see that's not finding
that right so that needs to be fixed
that's the fact that my doggy tools
configuration doesn't deal with these
packages I've mentioned this twice
before could you please get that trace
down short old
I'll check with Brian okay um I mean
this is
doesn't have any examples it's it's
totally pathetic but hopefully I'm
getting a meeting about chat
specifically soon
okay these entity pages again that's for
Alan and hopefully that's a separate
meeting okay right side correct I think
Alan said he wanted to have a brief
meeting checking out entity pages sure
I'll double-check with him well I'm
telling you he wants that so you know if
alex is here he can just deal with
getting that meeting am I making sense
is Alex here no then it's Terry yes I'm
here oh very good
okay okay this page isn't looking right
okay so it should have some things
already open for example or at least
thumb nailed that line is obviously
wrong etc the thumbnail issue is known
and is being fixed no but there's much
more that's wrong on this page there's
much more wrong um sure I I'll take a
look at the no no no it's not according
to spec it's not I'll take a look at
this Ilona I just went over the spec so
it needs do you need to talk to Alan
about it I don't know maybe the spec
hasn't been propagated properly here
makes sense yes that's obviously a bug
here great yeah
might be a dataset bug I don't know
that's also stupid there there are
several of the things in here are kind
of stupid
right this this some the height of the
airplane to you know the size of an atom
is stupid make sense right
i I don't know what tum what's needed to
get that right are you gonna pass that
talent or do I need to I will let him
know that's that's fine for here craft
this example right well no it's not a
question of this example it's a question
of the general case of what comes out in
these situations right right I mean I'll
use this as an example to start this yes
right okay fine
okay what is this that's that's
something that gets it's not for me to
knit this okay okay okay there should be
a list of net encoders there's a page
with a list of net encoders I don't know
um or maybe it isn't a page let's take a
look net encoder hours term that seems
to be
perfectly well misted to me what's wrong
with that
is there a page of necen Coda's that's a
guide page about net encoders um yes
where is new netbook Skype no no no no
wrong that doesn't contain a page about
net encoders it contains simply the
function net encoder itself to go what
I'm saying these individual net encoders
have their own sub pages eventually
there will be a guide page and like the
format stuff this will say net encoder
up here it'll just say listing of of net
encoder pages a fine but all the other
net encoder pages are on guide slashings
and netbooks that's at least that's you
know really yeah let me see that
okay I gotta go in a second um so if you
scoot down scoot a little yet there okay
fine add it to that okay I don't know
where it
get added to get added at the end I
don't know I'll check with ya I should
get at it at the end I think those are
in alphabetical order just added at the
end right okay okay
unity link I'm having a separate meeting
about right oh yes apparently that's on
yes yes I'm having a separate meeting
about it I don't have access to all your
meeting so I cannot okay so Alex should
be here is Alex here yes there is on
Monday okay very good
Thank You Roger yeah that can be a live
stream by the way people might enjoy
seeing that
okay graphs straw I don't understand
your statement that this is net it I'm
pretty sure that I didn't it this and I
don't know what on earth try G and n
quads and things are those don't look
right that's gonna require a separate
meeting with Tony okay okay
and this isn't for me to do that's
internal stuff okay okay great thanks
see you guys soon okay